الاطلالات
انا عشان كذا راح اقول لك بس هي الاطلالات
والفساتين كانت جوهر حفل الزفاف الملكي في
الاردن وحديث مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اناقه عادل وبساطه كندا حاضره في الثوبين
التي ارتدتهما العروس رجوى سيف اثناء عقد
القران وايضا خلال حفل الاستقبال والعشاء
المصمم ايليس صعب كان المساهم الاكبر في
ازياء العرس الملكي وترك بصمته وتوقيعه
على ثلاثه من اهم فساتين الحفل او
لهما عروس الاميره رجوى وفستان الملكه
رانيا خلال حفل الاستقبال وايضا فستان
اميره ويوس
[موسيقى]
ف
الاطلاله الاولى للعروس رجوى ال سيف اثناء
عقد القران من توقيع دار ايلي صعب ثوب
ابيض طويل ترافقه تنوره واسعه من الخلف مع
تاجر مرسع بالالماس يحمل عباره رجوى من
الله وفي حفل الاستقبال ارتدت الامير نجوى
فستانا ثانيا من تصميم
الموقوف والمطرز بالورود اما الامير
الحسين فارتدى بدله مستوحاه من تصميم
البتله والده الملك عبد الله الثاني التي
ارتداها في حفل زفافه عام
الملكه رانيا المعروفه باناقتها ارتدت
فستانين الاول اثناء عقد القران اسوا
الطويل بزخارف ذهبيه من جيور وخلال حفل
الاستقبال اختارت فستانا من دار اليسا
الاميره ايمان شقيقه ولي العهد الامير
الحسين اختارت فستانا للمصمم السعودي محمد
قاشي اما الشقيقه الصغرى الاميره سلمى
فاعتمد التوبه ازرق فيروزي من دار السلام
كارتني
اخيرا السيده عزه سديري والده العروس رجوى
ارتدت ثوبا بلون اللافندر تعلوه عباءه
يزينها التطريز بنفس اللون على الاكمام
والياقه ونحن سالنا الناس في الاردن
والسعوديه برايك من خطف الانظار بمظهره في
العرس الملكي الاردني نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
وقد خلق الله سبحانه وتعالى لنا ازواجا من
انفسنا لنسكن اليها
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله عليه يعني هو اللي لفت بنظر
اكثر واحد
ميرا اكيد الانسه نجوى هي من اكثر الناس
يعني اللفتوا الانظار
[موسيقى]
الملكه ما شاء الله الملكه رانيا بتجنن
بتجنن عن جد حلوه كتير كتير
[موسيقى]
عبدالله ما شاء الله عليه احسن من هيك ما
في
[موسيقى]
اكتر واحده كان شكلها حلو العروسه رجوى
الفستان والطرحه وكل شيء مره حلو اكثر
حاجه مفيده فيها التاج التاج كان جميل قوي
بصراحه مكتوب عليه رجوه من الله اكثر احد
لفت نظري الاميره كيت مره الامير ويليام
والله العريس لانه العريس ما شاء الله كان
يعني الزية حقه جدا جدا انيق زي عسكري
اكثر حد لفت نظري الملكه رانيا سمير
الحسين هي اكثر ملفته للنظر عجبت
ني وفستانها كان انيق جدا انيقه الامير
الحسين
كان اللبس حقه كلاسيك وحلو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
معنى لا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو الستايل
وخبيره المظهر لمى علاء الدين اهلا بك يا
لمى اهلا فيكم صباح الفل
طبعا موضوعنا مميز اليوم الزفاف الملكي
والاناقه الفائضه اللي كانت موجوده خلينا
هيك نبلش عشان نلحق نحكي عن كل الفساتين
وكل اللوكس يعني زي ما بنقول نبلش
باطلالات العروس
العروس كانت كتير مميزه انا بالاطلاله
الاولى برايي لانه كثير سنبل كل التفاصيل
كانت بالدين هلا طبعا الشغل الي صعب الي
صعب كتير مميز وكانت الاكسسوارات وانا
دائما بركز على الاكسسوارات تكون بسيطه
فهي تميزت فيه التاج كتاب عربيه من الله
هاي احدثها اياها الملكه رانيا وهي كلمه
للملكه رانيا رجل في ليله الحناء برافو
عليك والحلقه قديش سمبل مع الخاتم يعني ما
زادتها بالاكسسوارات طله كثير كانت مميزه
وكثير سمبل وطليق باميره
اذا التاج مكتوب عليه والحلق والخاتم ما
كسرت
الحركه كلها كانت بالصدر وبالذيل لها
اطلاله تانيه اطلاله العروس هذا نفس
الفستان من الخلف كثير حبيت لانه الشغل
كان كله بديل فمش مبين فظلت الاطلال كتير
من امان
تبع الصدر كتير حبيت طيب حلو اذا خلينا
نتكلم ايضا بانه
برح نتكلم عن بقيه هذه الصوره الثانيه اذا
بدك اضيف كتير اجا التعليقات على الفلات
الحذاء الفلات بس انا برايي انه هي اتبعت
بروتوكول الملكي ما بصير تكون اعلى من
الرجال وانا اظن هذا بروتوكول لازم يعتمد
بكل حتى بين عامه الشعب انه الست ما تلبس
وتتعمى تكون اطول من الرجل فانا كتير حبيت
انها كانت اقصر وبنفس الوقت الرياحه يعني
هي بدها تكون مرتاحه
هي وجدت الحل المناسب طيب فستان الاستقبال
هذا فستان اخر جميل هذا رائع
الكتير اجا عليه اعتراضات على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي انه ما بصير اميره تلبس
شيء مضر شي عصري وشي على الموضه انا برايك
لازم كلاسيك بس انا برايي اصلا بالقصور
الملكيه صار يكسروا هالمراسيم بطلوا
يتشبطوا فيها اطلاله رومانسيه فظيعه قلعت
الطرحه ضلت بالتاج اللي برضه الكتاب
العربي والسنسال حتى الكفوف الجلوزه
اعطاها طله رومانسيه كتير راقيه كثير
حبيت طيب الاطلاله التانيه للملكه رانيا
تالقت
هاي الاطلاله الاولى للملكه رانيا بفستان
اسود وفي طبعا اخرى راح الفستان الاول انا
اول ما شفته اول عشر ثواني بتعرف هي
ايقونه من ايقونه ايقونات الاناقه يعني
احنا كلنا بنطلع شو لابسه ونحب نقلدها اول
ما تلعب بالاسود هيك انخضيت بس اخذني 10
ثواني لما تاملت التفاصيل للديور بالكم
حتى الكلاتش اللي لابسه نفس التطريز
الحلقه اللي لابساه فيه نفس النقشه
التفاصيل الصغيره
ابداع هو الضحك كان جميل رائع جدا طيب الي
صعب بعد مره ثانيه في الاطلال الثاني
هلا عملت هي تعديل ضفت الكمام عليه وسكرته
من الامام بشوف التفاصيل اللي هي بتعتمدها
الكلاتش نفس اللون اللون العاجي مع اللولو
وحتى لبست تاج كان الملك مهديها اياه برضه
بالعربي اظن عظمه من الله او هيك شيء لبست
لكمل الاناقه انا كان عندي بس ملاحظه
صغيره انه لو لبسته لولو او ذهبي بس انه
باللغه العربيه وعليه احرف عربيه رائعه
اكيد في له حتى يعني الملك عبد الله اهدا
هي لها قيمه رمزيه ايضا عاطفيه بالنسبه
لها طيب ننتقل لام العروس ايضا اطلالتين
اول اطلاله بالبنفسجي الفاتح جميل جدا هذا
اللون هذا بدها تترك كانت في بصمه سعوديه
للارث السعودي السعوديه مشهوره جدا بالزهر
اللافندر او الخزامى بنزرع بشمال السعوديه
وبيعتمدوا هذا اللون بالسجاد حتى
الاستقبالات الرسميه وليس الاحمر فهي كانت
بدها تعلم هذا اللون لهيك لبسته طلع عليها
رائع مع الكلتش مع الشنطه اللبسه انيقه
وبامتياز وخاصه انه لها معنى كتير حساس
وكبير معنى وطني وثقافي الروح الى
الاميرات الاميره ايمان والاميره سلمى
الاميره ايمان كتير حبيت كلاسيكال بقوه
وهو للمصمم السعودي محمد العشي او قاشي
بقولوا له وبرضه تتلمز على يدين الي صعب
الي صعب بصمته كثير كبيره بهذا العمر
والاميره سلمى الاميره سلمى لبست لسلمى
اللون فرح زي ما هي بتحب عملت تعديلات غطت
لانه بالعاده مفتوح من الظهر حبيت كثير
يعني البساطه كانت تطغى على هذا العرس
جميل جدا ننتقل للاميره الله الي صعب ايضا
بالضبط وربحت يعني كل مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اعطوها احلى طله لانه فعلا كانت
انيقه جدا
متكامله حتى الاقراط مش مبينه هون كانت
كتير ملائمه للفستان
هذا الفستان الصبح سمعت عليه كتير تعليقات
وانا بايد يعني حطت البروش الملكي عليه مش
مناسب الاصفر مع اللون الزهري هلا يعتمد
نفس اللون بس كطلتها
الجسمها وهيك حلو عليها هذا الفستان بس
الاول كان انجح اوكي
عنا الشيخه موزه ايضا
هي ايقونه من ايقونات الاناقه فيعني ما في
حكي اللبسه كلها متناصفه عن شوفي الحلقه
اسود الحذاء مش مبين زهري ستان باللون
الكي بس انا حسيت وهذا رايي المتواضع انه
مش للمناسبه يعني بجوز لو
لبستان او حرير بس وقعت انه الطقس ابرد
لهيك لبست شي ثقيله شوي بس الدنيا بس كطلع
متكامله طيب والجل بعادل جل بايدن كتير
حبيت احكي عنها لانه هذا الفستان لبسته
قبل هالمره بعشا بالبيت الابيض وهو
للمعكره برافو عليك كتير مشهوره بالولايات
المتحده على فكره وشوفي قديش
بس انا حبيت انه رجعت لبسته كمان مره مع
انه السيده الاولى بالولايات المتحده وهذا
باكد فكره الاستدامه انه مش من الفستان
بنرميه يعني كان في امكانات
بنتها
بنتها شويه قاسي لهيك يعني السواد والحذاء
الاسود وشيء شوي قاسي لا او بجوز يبدا
تعطي الاضواء لامها ما بعرف بس يعني جيم
بايدن
اعترف للمره الاولى وردتيني لما انه انا
ما افهم شيء
اكيد الك نظره
الحلو مو حلو بس هذا البنات
ههه شكرا جزيلا
طبعت المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات